>>> WE'VE BEEN THROUGH THE 76
NAMES, BECAUSE OF THE TIE.
YOU TALK ABOUT, WOW, I WONDER
HOW THIS GUY DIDN'T MAKE IT OR
SHOULD THIS GUY HAVE POSSIBLY --
>> IT'S ALL SUBJECTIVE.
I HAVE A QUESTION.
>> WHICH OF THOSE NAMES.
>> THERE'S GUYS INFLUENCED MY
GAME.
I HAVE LOVE FOR ADRIAN DANTLEY
AND OBVIOUSLY JOHN DREW.
VINCE CARTER SHOULD BE ON THE
LIST.
>> ALL OF THESE GUYS, THEY HAVE
A CASE, WITHOUT QUESTION.
ALL OF THOSE GUYS HAVE A CASE.
IF I'M MISSING IT?
YAO MING WASN'T --
>> HE WASN'T ON IT.
>> HE SHOULD BE AT LEAST ON THE
MISSED LIST, PEOPLE THAT MISSED.
HE SHOULD BE A NAME THAT IS
GOING TO BE ASSOCIATED.
>> AS FAR AS, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LIFT.
>> MUTOMBO, CARTER, KING.
>> BERNARD, NEVER WANT TO MISS
BERNARD.
>> ALL OF THOSE GUYS COULD MAKE
A CASE.
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH GRANT
HILL.
>> ADRIAN DANTLEY.
>> WHEN HE WAS PLAYING, GRANT
HILL SHOULD HAVE BEEN ON THAT
LIST.
>> WHEN I SAW -- I HAD A PLACE
IN MY HEART FOR MUTOMBO WHEN I
VOTED ON THIS, BECAUSE I THINK
HE REPRESENTS NOT ONLY WHAT HE
DID ON THE FLOOR, FOUR-TIME
DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE YEAR,
HALL OF FAMER, NUMBER TWO IN
BLOCKS ALL TIME, BUT ALSO HOW HE
USED THE PLATFORM OF THE NBA
AFTER HIS PLAYING DAYS TO
FURTHER --
>> DID HE JUST BLOCK MY SHOT.
>> YEAH, HE DID.
>> FOR REPUTATION FOR ALL HE'S
DONE FOR THE HOSPITALS.
HE'S A GUY WHO REPRESENTS THE
BEST OF THE NBA IN TERMS OF
PRODUCT ON THE FLOOR AND AN EYE
FOR HELPING OTHER FOLKS.
SUCH AN AMBASSADOR FOR THE GAME.
>> A GREAT GAME AND A GREAT
PLAYER.
>> CAN I REPRESENT SOME GUYS --
I WAS A BIG FAN BEFORE I EVEN
TOUCHED THE BASKETBALL.
BUT GUYS LIKE ALEX ENGLISH,
ADRIAN DANTLEY, THOSE GUYS DON'T
GET ENOUGH CREDIT.
THEY LED THE LEAGUE IN SCORING.
THEY WERE TOUGH TO GUARD.
THEY WOULD LIVE IN THIS ERA,
PROBABLY AVERAGE 25, 30 POINTS A
GAME.
THERE'S A GROUP OF GUYS THAT
NEED TO BE RECOGNIZED.
>> D. WADE, PUT A PERIOD ON WHAT
WE'VE SEEN TONIGHT ON THE 75?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN DO
THAT.
I THINK WE DO UNDERSTAND ANY
TIME YOU CREATE A LIST, WHICH
IT'S TOUGH.
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOMEONE LEFT
OFF.
OF COURSE, I LOVE VINCE CARTER.
OF COURSE, I LOVE CHRIS BOSH,
DWIGHT HOWARD.
I LOVE THESE YOUNGER PLAYERS
THAT HAVE GREAT CAREERS.
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE
SOMEONE LEFT OFF.
>> CHRIS BOSH SHOULD BE ON THAT
LIST.
>> DENNIS JOHNSO